hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys that
brandy prize we're gonna check out the
trailer today for a oh i'm excited for
this is rated our Amy Poehler and Tina
Fey and sisters okay yeah I didn't know
it was rated art I get to be more
excited because you know like they
normally do like pg-13 type of comedies
yes cool they're both really cute for
comedians what does that mean well a lot
of female comics aren't that
good-looking
okay you know that's true crude sexual
content and language through drug use oh
well there's some heroin joke what's
your doom
I've been having a lot of fun I don't
need lotion in there yeah ain't your
need lotion in there we are looking for
an yard artisan to do some work on our
bushes I've been working on other
people's bushes really makes you want to
whack your weeds I was bigger than I
thought I'm sorry I got dirty really
fast
mom and dad sold our childhood home this
should have been passed on all we need
you to do is clean out your bedroom oh
boy damn shame that you never had your
night here we cannot have a party you
can divorce two years you can't avoid
putting yourself out there forever do
not work me like this there's so much to
do you that's invite that cute guy from
down the street
hey okay hi Maura I'm James I just
wanted to say hi so that's done it's a
lot of under teat but I think I'm
getting away with it
it's on backwards dress one of my apples
keeps rolling out of the bag I like the
story it tells with the fringe oh here
we go I've been thinking why will you
not drink tonight so I can let my freak
flag fly I would love to I heard you
were having a party from someone who got
invited it's okay dad this snazzy belt
and thank you yeah congrats on your
wrestling championship we need to say
goodbye to this house but we sure had
fun you
you're the type of badass that I'm
susceptible to let's say for just keep
going
it's my ballerina music box it really is
beautiful melody nope
while that did make me laugh a little
bit I feel like the movie itself won't
be that good but I feel like they'll
probably elevate it in some way I have
to agree with you I am glad we agree
ready particular judgment form sexual
tension of me right now I'm in a
relationship and so are you
leak from a little sexual tension you
know that it's her way out like it's too
much sexual thing you gotta find a
balance look like they tried a little
bit too hard to make it funny yeah yeah
it looked like oh this is gonna be rated
R so let's let's just go all out but it
doesn't it feels like forced and a
little cheap sometimes it doesn't feel
like there's not one thing there's
anything really unique to offer here
other than the fact that these two are
starting an r-rated flick well not
nothing about maybe a red band trailer
will change my mind
like really seeing why it's rated R
exactly you know I mean the joke with
the jack-in-the-box I think it was funny
what's what Veronica does every time she
comes in your face no yeah baby
don't I told you I'm like the feather
you secrete seen in this is no I was
gonna think I was just thinking that she
was a squirter I will not reveal that
personal information about my girlfriend
kind of feels like a drawn-out SNL skit
like the sisters having a party and like
I would have liked to have seen them
sort of it's cool if they're playing
characters but I would have I like it
when Amy Poehler Tina Fey like pretty
much play themselves hey you know I like
it when they do that
and I would have liked to have seen that
in an r-rated comedy okay do you know
what I think is missing in this one is
that I don't have much of a relationship
I feel like yes of course there feels
like they're friends and not like their
sisters I was confused at first yeah
because I was like I know it's called
sisters but I thought they were just
friends
especially with the way they interact
with each other even though they said
the other sister and the perfect sister
right right exactly
this feels like a teen comedy but with
older people it looks like they're
trying to get a wide demographic here
well I think that's the whole just
behind the movie is that they were
wanting to relive their past because
they didn't have a huge party when they
were attained so now that their parents
are selling their house from their
childhood they want to have it last -
wrong true but no it's it's the premise
of the movie but it looks like a typical
teen movie though but then again they
are perfectly cast for that because you
could see them him like a movie like
that in the 90s yeah you know so they
are cast well for people over their 40s
who are supposed to be doing that so I
don't know kind of just feels like a
marketing manipulation like well if we
get these actresses in their 40s but we
make it attract it to teenagers we get a
what I can see why they picked up the
film and decided to make it yeah but I
don't know ages I think they have a
pretty wide following anyway as far as
the demographic of their following Oh
totally
apart some reckon 30 rock and everything
else yeah absolutely
anyway if you needed the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects or you can
check out my channel - it's basically
you mean you can read face or you can't
write and work you can subscribe or you
can send a subscribing good no okay
what kind cross promotion is that well
that's what you made it sound like also
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope I don't have finder periscope